there's no stopping the spread
shortly after signing a decree chilean
president sevastian pinera and his wife
were ordered into a mandatory 14-day
quarantine
after being notified that a member of
their domestic staff had tested positive
to covert 19.
in the middle of the hot summer holiday
season infections in chile have
increased
35 percent in just one week
forcing authorities to declare
widespread lockdowns
and stiff restrictions on movement and
travel
health experts are warning of a
catastrophe of infections surpass
9 000 a day and with just a little less
than half that number right now
hospitals are already reaching their
maximum capacity
in neighboring peru intensive care units
have already reached it
unfortunately we do not have the
capacity to take care of all patients
because those who enter the icu
often leave in weeks or months
infections past the one million mark
this week
health workers have planned a nationwide
strike arguing they can't continue
working under current conditions
this despite some rare positive news
from the president
after lending difficult negotiations
which were frustrating at times
i can announce to you that we have
completed the purchase of the first
batch of the expected pandemic vaccine
but throughout latin america vaccines
will take months if not longer to make a
difference
freshly dug graves in the capital of
brazil's amazona
state illustrate that the health system
is on the verge of collapse
we are at the limit of our icu capacity
and medical clinics we are beating all
international records in these areas
some blame a new more contagious strain
of coronavirus for a vicious second wave
after a first wave that in fact has
never really ended
lucia newman al jazeera santiago